فوض رئيس المجلس العسكري في النيجر
الجنرال عبد الرحمن تيااني القوات المسلحه
في مالي وبوركينا فاسو بالتدخل في بلاده
اذا تعرضت لهجوم وكانت يعني التقى وفدا من
علماء نيجيريا زار للمره الثانيه بهدف
التوصل الى حل سلمي للازمه التي ناقشها في
واشنطن مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
والفرنسي والالماني والايطالي والبريطاني
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات اولها ما هي المعطيات
التي دفعت قاده الانقلاب لتفويض مالي
وبوركينا فاسو للتدخل عسكريا في بلادهم ثم
الرساله التي توجهها هذه الخطوه وتاثيرها
على فرص وطبيعه حل الازمه ثم دلاله اجتماع
مستشاريه الامن القومي الامريكي والفرنسي
والالماني والايطالي والبريطاني في واشنطن
لبحث ازمه النيجر في هذا التوقيت وما
امكانيه تاثير ذلك على موقفهم في نيابي ثم
ما هي سيناريوهات المتوقعه لاتجاهات
الاوضاع في النيجر في ظل تمسك قاده
الانقلاب بالمضي في اجراءاتهم ومن جهه
اخرى تزايد الدعوات الاقليميه والدوليه
للضروره استعاده النظام الدستوري بالبلاد
[موسيقى]
قبيله تجديد مجموعه اكواس دعوتها قاده
الانقلاب في النيجر للتراجع عن اجراءاتهم
واطلاق سراح الرئيس المحتجز واسرته وتاكيد
المجموعه مجددا ان خيار التدخل العسكري لا
يزال مطروحا على الطاوله فوض رئيس المجلس
العسكري في النيجرى الجنرال عبد الرحمن
تياني القوات المسلحه في مالي وبوركينا
فاسو بالتدخل في اراضي بلاده في حال تعرضت
لهجوم قرار ثمنه مالي وبوركينا فاسو
اللتان جددت تضامنهما مع النيجر لصد ما
وصفته بالعدوان المحتمل الذي تخطط له
تطور تزامن مع لقاء اجره اتيالي مع وفد من
علماء نيجيريا وصل الى نيامي الاربعاء
بتوجيه من رئيس وفد ايكواس الى النيجر
بغرض البحث عن حل سلمي للازمه بحسب رئيس
وفد العلماء الذي يراسه الشيخ عبد الله
بالالوه الذي يزور النيجر للمره الثانيه
في اطار هذه الازمه
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع نرحب بضيوفنا في هذه
الحلقه من الدكتور علي تاسع الاكاديمي
والدبلوماسيه السابق من ابو جاس صديق جربه
شيغوس الاستاذه المساعد في المركز
الاوروبي للدراسات الامنيه والمختص بالشان
الافريقي ومن باريس الدكتوره ليزلي فرن
مديره معهد دراسات العلاقات الدوليه
والاستراتيجيه في باريس اهلا بضيوف وابدا
بضيف من يام الدكتور علي تاسع لمحاوله فهم
ما الذي دفع بنيامى لاعطاء هذا التفويض
لكل من بوركينا فاسو
وطبعا العسكريين في بوركينا فاسو ومالي
بالتدخل
مرحب بك واهلا بضيوفك
الكريمين
احيي المشاهدين
الذي دفع الجيش او الحكومه العسكريه الى
اتخاذ هذا الاجراء هو تتويجا لما حدث او
لما قامت به كل من جمهوريه مالي وبوركينا
فاسو في الساعات الاولى من اعلان مجموعه
الاقويس بانها ستتدخل عسكريا تتذكرون ان
مالي وبوركينا في اعلان مشترك
ازهرت استعدادهما للانضمام الى النيجر من
اجل الدفاع
انها من اي تدخل عسكري من اي عدوان هل
هناك التطورات عسكريه دكتور علي هل هناك
تطورات عسكريه في الساعات الماضيه او
الايام الماضيه دفعت الى التسريع باتخاذ
هذه الخطوه
ليست هناك اي
تحركات عسكريه فقط لان مجموعه الاكواسيلات
لا تزال تلوح
بالتدخل العسكري لذلك
لتتم لكي تتم العمليه بين النادر وبوركينا
فاسو ومالي سمح او قرر قاره الحكومه
العسكريه في النيجر بانه تسمح لكل ممالي
وبوركينا بالتدخل في النيجر العسكريا قال
ما تعرض النيجر لاعتداء من اي دوله من دول
الاقوى فقط ربما يكون هذا من باب
الاستعداد للسلمي الذي يستعد للسلمي لابد
ان يريد السينما لابد ان يستعد للحرب فان
كان السلم فبه ونعمه واما اذا كان حربا
فتكون النيجر وهي وزميلاتها مستعده لذلك
ايا كانت المعطيات التي دفعت اتخاذ هذه
الخطوه من قبل
اسال ضيفي من ابوه سيد صديق جربه شيغو في
هذا التوقيت بالذات هناك وفد من العلماء
مرسل من قبل يلتقي بالقاده في النيامي
وبالتالي اي رساله توصلها هذه الخطوه بهذا
التفويض لبركينا فاسو ومالي من قبل من
يحكمون نيامي الان فيما يتعلق باي خطوات
تصعيديه او الاحتواء الوضع باعتقادك
ما ارغبه بقوله هو انه بدايه عندما بدا
هذا الوضع فان المجلس العسكري في النيجر
رفض استقبال الوفد من اكواس لكن كان هنالك
بعض
التحسن عندما استقبال وفد العلماء حيث كان
هنالك استخدام ماليه الصلاد العلميه
والدينيه والثقافيه بين
النيجر وبين وبين الدول الاخرى ان هنالك
اشخاص لديهم نفوذ بالتالي راينا هنالك نوع
من التقدم للمره الاولى
منذ استقبال المجلس العسكري لهذا الوفد
مره اخرى ايضا راينا الرئيس الجنرال عبد
السلام يقود
يقود الوفد وكان هنالك ايضا استقبال لهم
والرئيس الذي كان
رهينا في المجلس في المبنى الرئاسي
بالتالي اعتقد ان هذه مؤشرات ايجابيه على
الاقل قد تكون الاساس لبدء النقاش بين
مجلس العسكري في ميامي والاكواز كما
تعرفون فان قال الجنطه مجلس العسكري انهم
منفتحون للنقاش وكان هذا تغييرا ايجابيا
وكان هنالك للمره الاولى حيث انه كان
هنالك نوع من
من قبل الاكواز لاعاده البلاد الى المسار
الديمقراطي بالاعتماد على السؤال الذي
طرحته على الزميلي من يمي فيما يتعلق
لماذا سمح المجلس العسكري لمالي وبوركينا
فاسو بتوقيع اتفاق يسمح لهما بشكل قانوني
بالتدخل
اذا كان هنالك اعتداء برايي ما دفع المجلس
العسكري الى هذا الامر انهم كان لديهم
كان هنالك تواصل وتم اختيار هذا الاعلان
اتى من الاكواز تم اختيار يوم محدد للتدخل
او للعمليات العسكريه وهذا الاعلان من
الاكواس اريد
باعتقادي ان المجلس العسكري يريد ان يقول
انه مستعدون للمواجهه فانهم وحلفائهم في
مالي وبوركينا فاسو سيكونون مستعدين
ويريد ارادوا ان يظهروا هذا الاستعداد
بخطوات واضحه علينا ان نتذكر ان قاده
الانقلاب قالوا انه اذا
لانه في الوثيقه التي صدرت عن البيت
الابيض او هذا الاعلان قالوا انك كل هذه
الدول تدعم الاكواس ولكن الاكواس تمسك
بطرف الخيط من جهه تهدد
بالتدخل العسكري وبالتالي كما لو انهم
يدعمون الشيء ونقيده وبالتالي من الصعب ان
نرسم فعلا
اذا كان هناك فعلا وحده صف او وحده موقف
بين هذه الدول الخمس اعتقد اننا
او اننا حققنا تقاربا بين الموقفين
الفرنسي والامريكي منذ ايام ويبدو ان
الولايات المتحده لم تحصل على ما تتوقعه
من
المجلس العسكري
وبالتالي يبدو ان هناك تقريبا وحده موقف
بين فرنسا والولايات المتحده اما المانيا
وايطاليا فلم تدعم تدخل عسكريا وبالتالي
لا نعرف حتى الان انه ملف لا يبدو مستقرا
نستيقظ في الصباح ونقول انتهينا من الخيار
العسكري ولكن في المساء ننام على فكره
اننا سوف نبدا التدخل العسكري فيليه او
سوف نشهد تداخل عسكريا
غداه هذا اليوم ولكن
اذا كان هناك هذا الاعلان من الدول
الثلاثه بين بوركينا فاسو ومالي ونيجر
ساره
الحق في التدخل في الاراضي اراضي النيجر
هذا يعني اننا بدانا نسمع اصدقاء الحرب او
الجسمات العسكريه وهذا مقلق واعتقد ان
العسكريين في النيجر يدركون
ان هناك تحرك عسكري معين او تحضير له في
المنطقه وبالتالي يجب ان ننظر الى موقف
الجزائر هل ان الجزائر قلقه الى درجه سوف
تبعث بوزير الخارجيه الى غانا الى بنا في
محاوله للتفاوض هذا يعني اذا حصل ذلك هذا
يعني ان هناك قلق فعلي من الخيار العسكري
طيب انا هذا المسعى هذا الاجتماع الامريكي
مع الدول الاوروبيه ومخرج به هذا البيان
ايضا يدخل في اطار ايضا ما تقوم به ايضا
مسؤولون امريكيون فقبيل الاعلام عن جوله
لمساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي للشؤون
الافريقيه تستمر اربعه ايام وتاخذها لعده
دول افريقيه منها نيجيريا وغانا
وساحل العاج والسنغال وطوغو لبحث ملف ازمه
النيجر وسبل حلها كشفت واشنطن عن اجتماع
لمستشار امنها القومي جيكس كما ذكرنا مع
نظرائه فرنسا والمانيا وايطاليا وبريطانيا
في البيت الابيض واضافت واشنطن ان مستشاري
الامن القومي للدول الخمس شددوا على اهميه
اعاده النيجر الى طريق النظام الدستوري
ودعم الدوري القيادي لمجموعه
هذا ما يحيل الى سؤال ضيفي من الدكتور علي
تاسع عن طبيعه ما يحمله الوفد العلماء
طبعا المبعوث من قبل الى نيامي جاء في
المره الاولى ثم عاد كان هناك بعض
التسريبات تقول بان هذا الوفد حمل مقترحا
من قبل المجلس المجلس العسكري في النيابه
عن فتره انتقاليه لمده ثلاث سنوات وانه تم
رفض هذا المقترح او هذه المبادره من قبل
وبالتالي باعتقادك او هل تسربت اي معلومات
عما يحمله هذا الوفد للعلماء هذه المره
فيما يتعلق
او اسمح لي اولا ان الصحيحه ما قالته
ضيفتك من فرنسا بان الولايات المتحده لم
تجد ما تريده من الجيش او من العسكر من
المجلس العسكري الحاكم في النيجر بل ان
الولايات المتحده وجدت ما تريد لانها تريد
ان لا تقترب جمهوره النيجر من روسيا وقد
اعلن ذلك رئيس الوزراء محمد الامين الزين
اكد بان النيجر لا تستعد او ليست مستعده
في الوقت الحاضر للتوجه الى روسيا اذا
امريكا مطمئنه من هذا الجانب اما ما يتعلق
دكتور علي دكتور علي قبل ان تجيبني على
سؤال اريدك ان تعلق على هذا الخبر العاجل
نقل على المراسل الجزيره قاده الانقلاب في
النيجر يطلبون من السفير الفرنسي المغادره
خلال 48 ساعه ماذا عن هذا التطور
الاعلان فرنسا يعني هي المتحركه دائما هي
التي تريد هذا التدخل العسكري ليس الا
والا ايطاليا والمانيا والدول الاوروبيه
كلها عكس تعرف ما هي الكوارث التي يمكن ان
تحدثها في هذه المنطقه اذا حدث تدخل عسكري
من اي جانب كان والمجموع الاوروبيه تعرف
انه ليس لمجموعه الاكواس اي قوه يمكنها ان
تتدخل فالذريعه ايضا جاءت من فرنسا هي
التي تريد ان تتدخل والتحركات فرنسا هي
التي تدفع الجيش الى ربما اظن اذا كنت
هناك تقارب لوجهه نزر بين
المجلس العسكري وروسيا ستكون فرنسا هي
التي ستدفع الى ذلك والا هؤلاء القاده
الجدد ليس في نيتهم ان يتوجهوا الى ذلك
اذا تشدد فرنسا وتمسكها بالتدخل العسكري
هو الذي يدفع بالجيش الى التشدد والتسلق
وظيفه
عن هذا تطور ساعود لك الدكتور علي اعذرني
ولكن ساذهب في باريس الدكتوره ليزني عن
هذا التطور
مغلى تمنح للسفينه الفرنسي حتى يغادر انمي
مدتها 48 ساعه ماذا عن هذا التطور
براي هذا التصعيد جديد في الوقت الحالي
انا سمعته بالخبر حين نقلتموه وبالتالي
ليس لدي فكره عن الحجج التي اودت
بطلب
بالمجلس العسكري ان يطلب
رحيله لابد من وجود التسريبات حول تدخل
عسكري صراحه لا يمكنني ان اجيب لان
المعلومات غير مكتمله لدي ولكن كما اسلفت
هناك اذا جو من تدخل العسكري كما اسلفت
اجابه على او ردا على ما تفضل به ضيفكم هو
محيط نعم العسكريون قال ورئيس وزراء زين
ذكر بان المجلس العسكري في النيجر لا يريد
التقرب من روسيا ولكن هناك نقطه اخرى
وكانت مهمه في النقاشات كما يبدو
الا وهي ان النيجر كان يريد الاستمرار في
التعاون مع بال وبوركينا فاسو وحول هذه
النقطه بالتحديد وكما اعتقد فان توترات
بين الولايات المتحده والمجلس العسكري
مستمر ضيفي من ابو جربه اعود الى سالته
عليه ضيفي من نيامعا طبيعه ما يحمله هذا
الوفد هل من جديد قد يبعدنا على الحل
العسكري ويرجع
كفه الحل الدبلوماسي
هذا ما اعتقده اذا ما نظرنا وعلينا
نظرنا الى التدخل العسكري هل يتمتع الدعم
والتاييد من المجتمع الدولي اعتقد الان ان
النتائج نتيجه هذا
الجواب سيكون معقدا ومختلطا اعتقد بشكل
عام هنالك مقاومه لاي تدخل عسكري اذا ما
نظرنا الى الاعلان الاخير من قبل الاتحاد
الافريقي قال
انهم يلاحظون الجهود التي تبذلها الاكواس
لكنهم اخبروا مفوض الاتحاد الافريقي الذي
يقوم بمراقبه
الطابعات الاقتصاديه والسياسيه
والاجتماعيه لاي تدخل عسكري علينا ان
نتذكر ان الاتحاد الافريقي لم يقل انه
يدعم اي تدخل عسكري من قبل الاكواس ايضا
شيء فيما يتعلق بالامم المتحده الامم
المتحده قامت باطلاق بيانات وتعليقات
متعدده حول النيجر لكنها تلمت تذكر انها
تدعم التداخل العسكريه للاكو اسماء قالوا
فيما يتعلق بما يحمله الوفد هذه المره في
عودته للمره الثانيه الى نيامي وهنا اعود
الى ضيفي الدكتور علي ليجيبني ان كانت
لديه معلومات عن ما يحمله هذا الوفد من
العلماء في عودته الى نيامي
تتذكرون ان وفد الاولى جاء الى النيجر في
المره الاولى لم ياخذ اي رساله من
قناه الجيش والحكومه العسكريه في النيجر
الى رئيس الاقوى الذي هو رئيس نيجيريا لكن
الوفد الثاني الذي جاء بعد وفد العلماء
وهدى الرئيس الاسبق لنيجيريا عبد السلام
ابو بكر هذا الوفد نقل رساله من مجموعه
وتحديدا من رئيسها بان الاكواس تطالب
الجيش بان يتراجع
وحمل رئيس
المجلس العسكري في النيجل اما لا هذا
الوفد رساله بانه لا يمكن التراج يمكن
النقاش في كل شيء الا في مساله عوده
الرئيس بازم الى السلطه ولما سال الصحفيون
الرئيس الاسبق للنيره عبد السلام وحسب
نظركم انتم اتعتقدون انهم يمكن ان
يتراجعوا قال لا انا اعتقد انه ما دام
قبلوا انه يمكن مناقشه كل ما عدا هذا
فيمكن لمجموعه تناقش اشياء اخرى غير هذه
واعتقد ان رئيس نيجيريا ارسل هو مدرك بان
شعبه يرفض تماما رفضا قاطعا هذا التدخل
وحكام الولايات المجاوره للنيجر يرفضون
احد التدخل
ونوابه او اقول اعضاء مجلس الشيوخي يرفضون
ويعرفوا يقينا انه لا يمكن القيام باي شيء
لان حتى بعض اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ لوحوا بعزل
رئيس نيجيريا لو تقدم باي حركه الشيوخ
فانا اعتقد ان ربما رئيس نيجيريا تفهم
الوضع
وكلف هؤلاء العلماء برساله اخرى يمكن ان
ياتوا بها حول ما يمكن فعله اطلاق سراحه
الرئيس الاسبق او رئيس المعزول وكذلك نقص
او مراجعه المده التي
حددتها او حددها المجلس العسكري من ثلاث
سنوات يمكن ان تعود الى شهور حتى يمكن انت
عبر المناقشه لكن اذا صمم الاقوس على انه
لا نقاش الا عن تنازل فهذا لا هذه
المؤشرات حتى الان الواصله الى حد التضارب
بين هناك فسحه لحل سياسي من خلال ما ذكرته
الان ومؤشره التصعيد من خلال خبر الاخير
بطلب من السفينه الفرنسي بالمغادره وهنا
اسال ضيفتي من باريس استمعنا اليوم الى
وزير الخارجيه الروسي يحذر من تدخل عسكري
في النيجر بان يطال المنطقه برمتها ماذا
عن الحسابات الروسيه الصينيه في حال حدوث
اي تدخل عسكري في هذه المنطقه برايك
دكتوره
اتحدث عنه لاف من روسيا وكذلك ما تحدثت
عنه الصين والجزائر هذا كله يشير الى قلق
كبير من التدخل العسكري لهذا
ان هناك عناصر هذه الليله تشير الى احتمال
ان يكون هناك تحرك عسكري امل وان لا يحصل
طبعا هذا سيكون كارثيا كل ما ذكر يشير
ويؤشر الى اننا نسير في مسار التدخل
العسكري ولهذا السبب
نشعر بالقلق هذا المساء لانه لا روسيا ولا
الجزائر ولا الصين ستتحدث بهذه الطريقه لو
لم يكن هناك خطر فعلي وبالتالي اعتقد ان
الوضعيات الزم ويتصاعد وبدانا نشهد ذلك
بعد ان طالب النيجر من السفير الفرنسي ان
يغادر اضيف الى انه هذا العصر
حسب ما قاله ضيفكم من يامي ولكن اعتقد هذا
العصر حصلات مظاهره لاشخاص من النيجر امام
مركز العسكري الذي يتواجد فيه فرنسيون
وبالتالي بدات تتازم الامور
شكرا لك يا دكتوره
معهد دراسات العلاقات الدوليه
والاستراتيجيه في باريس وكذلك الشكر لضيفي
من ابو جاس صديقو استاذ مساعد المركز
الاوروبي للدراسات الامنيه مختص بشان
الافريقي وكذلك لضيف مينيامي الدكتور علي
التاسع الاكاديمي والدبلوماسي السابق
الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج ما
وراء الخبر الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]